زارت منظمه الصحه العالميه وشركائها
مستشفى الشفاء وسلمت الامدادات اليه كما
زارت ثلاثه مستشفيات اخرى في غزه في قوافل
متعدده وسط مشاهد من الياس والدمار وقال
شون كيسي مسق فريق الطوارئ الطبي بمنظمه
الصحه العالميه ان القتال المستمر
والاعداد الهائله من الجرحى قلصوا قدره
المستشفى الذي كان في يوم من الايام
الاكبر في قطاع
غزه
عدت الى مستشفى الشفاء الاكبر في غزه
للمره الثالثه خلال الاسبوع الجاري تسود
حاله من البؤس المطلق حيث المرضى ملقون
على الارض ومن المستحيل تقريبا المشي في
الممرات حالات حريجه واطباء وممرضون
يتدافعون تماما والناس يصرخون قائلين انهم
بحاجه الى الدم لابنائهم الذين يموتون لا
يوجد شيء تقريبا يمكن لهذا الفريق الطبي
الصغير جدا القيام به لمساعده كل هؤلاء
الاشخاص انها فوضه مطلقه وهي السائده وفي
الواقع حدث هذا حتى بعد ان اخبرنا طاقم
المستشفى ان القتال قد هدا اخيرا لكن
القتال متواصل على مدار اليوم حيث يصل
اشخاص باصابات حرجه وليس هناك سوى طاقم
صغير جدا
لمساعدتهم ك خطر المجاعه في غزه وحتى هنا
في المستشفى يقول الجميع انه ليس لديهم
سوى الارز في كثير من الاحيان يتناولون
وجبه واحده فقط في اليوم وهم جائعون
الجميع يريد
الطعام